zowie was once the king of the gaming
mouse Market they made products that
were built for pros used by pros and
nobody could rival their incredible
iconic shapes but in order to stay on
top zowie needed to innovate when other
companies inevitably came up and stole
their Thunder one Mouse manufacturer in
particular became the go-to head clicker
for many CS go Pros oh here it is yeah
enjoy
sorry sir how's your clutch so far
because it's just two kills away we got
off it he's got him off that 10 seconds
is everything to your liking oh my God
is this exactly how you wanted it
it's still Landing over the past few
years vaxi has become something of a
household name
especially within the camera strike
Community because their mice were
cheaper used newer Tech and were
arguably just as good they've become one
of zowie's biggest Rivals but as vaxi's
first wireless mouse their greatest
creation yet
[Applause]
all right so before we get to the video
I want to remind you all that we have
merch head over to shop.thescore.com and
check out our Esports collection I've
heard that you might even get a source 2
Beta code with one of our hoodies yeah
like I can't say that all right so it's
no secret that zowie have long been
considered the goat when it comes to
Mouse shape plenty of players myself
included swear by them and it has been
that way forever back in 2010 in
collaboration with Counter-Strike
Legends Heaton and spawn zowie released
the ec1 and ec2 two mice that went on to
become Staples within the FPS Community
Counter-Strike players in particular
fell in love with their shape and the
fact that you could adjust all the
settings by using buttons on the bottom
of the mice this meant that the pros
didn't have to worry about downloading
any software onto the PCS that they were
using On LAN Zoey's products were quite
literally made for the pros but since
the shape didn't necessarily work for
everyone zawi eventually expanded their
lineup with the s f k and z a series
mice their products now covered nearly
every shape and size that you could
imagine and even Pro players who
preferred ambidextrous mice had options
all right
flashes
I don't see you
I had nothing short of a Stranglehold on
the Cs go player base the majority of
Pros were using their products sure
but as it turns out zowie may have taken
this for granted as other companies
began implementing Wireless technology
and overall better components many Pros
began jumping ship and to make matters
worse some of zawi's founding members
left the company to start their own
ventures in April of 2020 a group of
former zowie employees officially
announced the arrival of vaxi a
peripherals company aimed at serving the
Esports Pro scene the community was
rightfully excited to see what kind of
products they would produce and they
didn't have to wait long to find out in
August of that same year vaxi presented
their initial offering to the public the
vaccine designed ziegen np1 was a
collaboration with Japanese
Counter-Strike Legend Napo and because
it shared a similar shape and size with
zawi's S2 and ec2 models even die hard
zowie purists were excited to try it out
now there's a lot of hype behind this
mouse as the original creators of the
Azalea mice decided to make another
mouse under a new name and we all know
how influential they have been in the
past and shaping the landscape of gaming
mice today there's no denying that this
is one of my most anticipated mice of
2020. it's great to see somebody
involved with an influence in the
creation of these shapes and designs of
mice vaccine
mp01 really did not
go short in any area of this mouse and
the build quality on this mouse is
fantastic terrific Splendid whatever way
you want to put it this is a well-built
mouse the np01 was extremely well
received especially considering it was
vaxi's first ever release within a few
months players all over Counter-Strike
were opting to use the np01 over their
trusted zowies vaxi's Newfound
popularity within the Cs scene allowed
them to quickly pump out new and
improved mice with different shapes and
in some cases lighter weight they have
essentially done what everyone expected
them to do from the start vaccine made
great mice with great shapes that
rivaled their initial creations at zawi
and in most cases they were actually
better but just like zowie Vexy mice
were still missing one crucial feature
while every other manufacturer was
showing off their latest and greatest
wireless tech zowie and vaxi fans were
begging both companies to ditch their
clunky paracords and go wire free now
for zowie there was quite a lot of
pressure to do this fans of their
products had literally been waiting
years for Zoe to Go Wireless and we're
beginning to get a little impatient so
back in January they finally caved and
announced Wireless versions of the EC
they were however criticized for its
high price tag and slightly outdated
3370 sensor but the real cherry on top
was vaxi's announcement of a wireless
version of the XE just four days after
zowie released theirs the XE was cheaper
than zawi's Wireless EC came with a
newer sensor and gave fans real insight
into how their new favorite product was
being made vaccine released the XE
Wireless alongside a video that
explained why they use certain
components and why the mouse weighed in
at 76 grams the company's transparency
has definitely earned them a lot of
respect from fans over the past couple
of years if you haven't watched that
video I would definitely recommend it if
you are a peripheral junkie I really
really enjoyed the video that baxi
released a couple of days ago where
they're kind of explaining you know why
they're going with a 3370 versus you
know 33.95 or whatever I've always been
a fan of maybe not implementing
something first but implementing it
correctly right so even if they don't do
Wireless at first but they do wireless
now and they do a really good job at it
you know our battery life is great if
you're not getting any delay or any
latency issues Pro still require these
tools to work right and they need them
to be perfect pretty much so maybe they
took a longer longer than you know
expected by the community or whatnot but
I'm all for it at the end of the day as
long as they do it well now after all
that I'm sure you're eager to know how
the Mouse actually performs thankfully
vaccine were super kind and sent us a
wireless XC so let's find out and now
the guy who actually knows what he's
talking about Hey look
it's me the guy who in this one
particular circumstance actually knows
what he's talking about
take that Colton you controller loving
casual so yeah what do I think about
vaxi's XE Wireless
I think that it's a banger
for the most part first things first the
packaging which is made up entirely of
recyclable paper and cardboard you open
it see a mouse a cable and a dongle
that's it it's simple and non-wasteful
there's also zero plastic which I really
appreciate
all that actually cares about is how the
product performs and cutting costs on
packaging is a great way to bolster that
as for the mouse itself it's basically a
G Pro with a zowie grade adjustability
interface the clicks are super crispy as
are the side buttons and have little to
no post travel the scroll wheel gives no
cause for complaints but I mean I'm a
I'm a zowie user my standards aren't
very high speaking of zowie like I said
everything is fully adjustable from the
bottom of the mouse powered DPI polling
rate and click response speed this means
that you don't need to install any
supplementary software though you can if
you want it's called the competitive
firmware and allegedly offers better
responsiveness at the expense of battery
life unlike zowie there is a function
button at the top of the mouse that
allows you to easily check battery life
which according to vaxi is 90 hours in
standard mode and half that in high
speed mode and when the competitive
firmware compared to the G Pro the XE
feels I don't know built better it comes
off as less dinky and toy-like in the
hand and to me has a tighter more
succinct feel I also really like the
matte surface which feels a lot less
likely to wear off than zowies all in
all the XC seems like a cheaper arguably
better G Pro I can't speak to the weight
difference because I personally am not a
fan of ultra light mice but if you're a
fan of this G Pro shape I personally
would recommend an XC over a G Pro
speaking of the shape that's the one
thing about this mouse that I expected
to hate a lot more than I did I do not
like flat backed mice the zowie EC
series uh hate it those who know me know
that I am a long long time za11 user
precisely because I cannot use a mouse
unless the hump is shifted towards the
back that said I really didn't mind the
shape of the EXE the hump seems to be
ever so slightly pushed to the rear
which did make a difference I obviously
wish it was shifted even more but I must
admit it is a master flea design shape
though I would expect nothing less from
members of the original zowie crew it
felt okay to play with and I hit
crispier shots than I anticipated but
the reality is that there is just one
thing about this mouse that I simply
cannot Overlook size the vaxi XE
Wireless is a phenomenal Mouse
that is categorically not for me like a
lot of new age mice the XE is simply too
small I love vaccine seriously both the
outset and XE are amazing mics that I
would switch to in a second but
unfortunately my hands are 20 by 10 and
a half centimeters long until they
release an XL version it's back to zowie
for me that said I recognize that I am
in the minority and do think that the XC
is a home run for folks with normal
sized hands it boasts a safe carefully
constructed ambidextrous shape that
vaccine were smart to put forward as
their first Wireless offering the day
they go bigger I'm there and that was
the guy who actually knows what he's
talking about so there's no doubt that
the guys over at vaccine have made one
incredible Mouse hell it might even be
better than the wireless EC that their
former company zowie just released and
it comes as no surprise that Pros are
already trying it out and plenty of
casuals will tell you that Vexy mice are
the way of the future but despite the
high price tag and inferior Hardware
when compared to other manufacturers
there are still many loyal fans willing
to foot the bill once zowie adds a
wireless option for their favorite
shapes which might actually happen
sooner thanks to some healthy
competition between these two companies
vaccine basically gave zowie a kick in
the butt and made them realize that in
order to stay relevant they needed to
release new better products so for now
I'm holding out for zowie to make some
Wireless z-as
but if someone else wants to make one
first
I'm there
xiaoi makes me want to scream into a
pillow great the EC went
Wireless what did the fkz-a and S users
care like oh but it's gonna take
time it's gonna take I mean you had a
bro like yeah
want someone to make a z a11 clone not a
za12 clone not a za13 clone